what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves another
trailer for The Mandalorian season three
you are looking at the crew today that
will be covering it on the channel we of
course got John John with all the
knowledge John bring it today
every Easter eggs the force to leave a
like do that and of course we got
Michael Tessler who I've been covering
the bad batch season two with one of our
most knowledgeable Star Wars gentlemen
I've ever known I think that was a
sentence I said how are you Michael I'm
so freaking excited uh this season of
the Mandalorian is gonna be
you think so I think so I mean it's it's
like if you watch the Clone Wars if you
watched Rebels if you watched any kind
of or played any you know Mandalorian
adjacent content it's just gonna be
phenomenal looks like it's time I mean
we gotta go back to Mandalore all right
guys let's do this
[Music]
the people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy
damn nice what do we stand for
I already have thoughts
not just learning about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate
the Galaxy
very true yeah
you'll never be lost
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven for my
transgressions whoa
Pele
this is the way
there's something dangerous happening
out there whoa is that of course big
enough for you
it'll be too late
OG helmet Whoa We did an order 66
flashback oh my God hang on kid
oh
baby baby
I'm just coming back
this is the way this is the way
oh dang
wow it looks okay yeah it could be
better it could be more exciting oh man
that's a trailer right there it looks
like we're gonna see some Order 66
flashback yeah probably explaining a
little bit more expanding upon the grogu
yeah which is so exciting to figure out
how the heck did little baby grogu make
it all that time yeah we saw some of
that in season two didn't we oh we saw a
little bit but somebody had to help him
true true well I mean what I loved first
off about this trailer was just the very
beginning of it is going back to the
heart of what is a Mandalorian today
because you got all these different
divisions you know if you think of it
like a religion it's like you got a
bunch of different denominations of
mandalorians I mean even in the last
season when bocatan first met up with
dinjarin she calls that what his way of
being a Mandalorian right which is funny
because then she part she was part of
the Night wall
night owls which is
Death Watch and then death watches with
saved dinjarin yeah that's what I mean
it's like the subsex and that's what the
beginning of this trailer was exploring
the topic of like Hey we're all divided
right now yeah and we're constantly
having a goddamn Civil War and now we
need to find a way of of unity so it
seems like this will be the unity of
mandalorians I feel like it's going to
be one of the coolest expansions on
Mandalorian culture because we're going
to see different kinds yet some type of
way of maybe the one look at some
freaking Beast for the first time ever
maybe maybe or maybe we'll have some
more wart yeah because you know what's
better though it's called star piece it
was really cool to see Mandalore just
like I mean it was alluded to so many
times the devastation that was wrought
it kind of reminded me when we when we
saw that Mandalorian helmet just kind of
covered in Ash and and rust uh of some
of those like Rebels episodes where the
empire was testing out ways to take on
uh bescar armor you have so much of what
they developed during the Clone Wars so
much of what was developed even before
that with the Knights of the Old
Republic it was just nice seeing like
little subtle Inspirations from all
those different parts of Star Wars lore
just kind of all coming to fruition and
the season I'm super jazzed I'm
especially interested Bo Katan where
she's gonna land and where she's been a
little absent in these trailers well I
think I think it's because she might
very well be our antagonist I mean she
would make a lot of sense to be but I'm
also like kind of on our side a little
bit I also just have to say like seeing
the the N1 uh starfighters even if you
don't watch book of boba for any other
reason just for that life
episode was like
there might be a lot of confused people
who didn't watch book of Boba Fett who
were like yeah wait a minute why are
they back together what what did Luke
what was going on plus you know he's
also motivated to reclaim being an
actual Mandalorian as well so this one
could be like really big and epic and
also probably the most personal but yeah
John yes what'd you think man we got a
side noobs we got uh no there's plenty
in here man no you're like with grief
cargo like I was he looks all Regal this
time around well yeah this trailer gave
me two things it gave me a thematic hope
but it also just gave me that punch of
this felt like watching the trailer for
like a big Blockbuster sequel to
something where it's like okay the story
is continuing but now we've got even
more of everything that was so cool
about the story up until this point and
I think that if they can combine all the
beautiful world hopping and the
struggles of Mandalore with a theme I
think of Andor and they've done a really
nice job of exploring the political
spectrum of Star Wars and I feel like
hear what you could do is in a subtle
way do a rumination on the struggles of
faith in a world like this because you
guys were talking about like the
Mandalorian culture is so spread out
fractured and otherwise that I think you
can could do a lot of really interesting
stuff with that while also maintaining
the nomadic quality that the show has
had this feels like it will be maybe a
slightly more serialized blend of the
episodic serial storytelling they like
to do here it certainly looks more
consistent than the book of books yeah I
think that's something that I I'm
excited for is for the store to have
just a bit more Focus which I think it
will definitively have for this season
but it's also easy to forget that
Mandalore is not the only Mandalorian
Planet you know we're talking about what
is in essence a small Empire in of
itself and these various factions that
exist in these places there's so much
about this as it seems to be building up
to getting the development of the first
order
and you and also the explanation of what
a snoke is
but you see all the Snopes down in
snokeville Craig
do you see Dr Pershing looks like he's
in Coruscant was that did I read the
trailer footage correctly that
definitely struck me as Coruscant or any
kind of other major I mean that has to
be Coruscant yeah lighting or I mean or
they just overlapped his lines do you
want footage from course but it looked
like he was actually traveling
throughout Coruscant yeah which it
should be noted is is technically not
the capital of the new Republic uh which
really noted
but I always kind of wondered you know
because it was it was rotating uh it
ended up in hosnian Prime at the time of
the force awakens uh and dweeb
chandrilla why are you here yeah
it's exciting to see you know Coruscant
didn't necessarily really have a great
run of it in the days after the Empire
what do you mean uh you know just major
urban center that you know leaned
heavily on an imperial police force that
suddenly disappeared at the end of the
war and an underfunded New Republic you
know which was putting all of its
philosophy here no I was going to say it
looks fine unless it's a flashback
interesting point or this is just a clip
from Blade Runner you guys yeah just
slipped it in there first and foreign
I think because they showed that and
then they went to the flashback of what
will look like Order 66 yeah which is a
nice I mean good to establish that we're
going to be spending some time in the
past I love that we can do that through
the lens of grogu too where it's not
just like oh we're just doing a
flashback for the sake of a flashback
but it's as certain things happen to
grogu they have this Force connection
that allows them to to
is that just PTSD is that what I'm
describing right now I think so that's
post-traumatic Force disorder
well guys um I thought this was an
amazing trailer I can't wait to cover
this show we're all gonna have fun yes
sir sure are fun right sir have fun and
uh use the force to leave a like what
did you guys think about this trailer
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below let's send this with a
Maria Hammond Maria in a lot of ways I
like to think I'm your baby grogu and
you're my tin jar sure just taking care
of me
and then John tell you're like the
second child you know you're like you're
like I'm like a Droid that you kick
around and you keep on hand just in case
you're like we have to take care but
really you know I'm gonna take all the
credit
sure and then Michael you're you're like
a Charming side character who makes a
big sacrifice leaves a big impression or
is just Panther yeah sure yeah that's
true like I don't really know about that
Michael guy you keep him around I'm a
scruffy looking Nerf herder and that's
why they keep me around but Maria you
have graced us with your presence and so
much physical items as well but so much
time and attention has been given to us
uh for such a long time now and I'm
excited to keep you in my life for at
least the remainder of 2023 sure we'll
see how my attitude changes and if you
want to leave by 2024 but I'm hoping
that for the remainder of time I'd love
to renew your contract if we can so yeah
but thank you for being such a such a
sweetheart and I love you dear hope I
gotta reply to you I know I got a
message review on Twitter I gotta reply
to you and I'm a little late there but
talk soon
foreign